bonjour supplée mathis et merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors le gouvernement britannique
semble complètement débordé par cette
crise sanitaire la france qui a décidé
de restreindre
voilà les conditions pour les voyageurs
en provenance du royaume uni ce que le
pays risque d'être isolé une fois de
plus
je crois de fait le pays est un peu
isolé actuellement bon la crise touche
tout la plupart des pays occidentaux et
même au delà mais ce qui se passe en
angleterre est important parce que
au-delà de la crise gérée plus ou moins
bien et plutôt moins bien selon
l'opinion par le gouvernement il y avait
effectivement une crise de confiance
très londres vis-à-vis du gouvernement
de boris johnson ce qui s'est passé hier
aux élections l'union chante cher c'est
à dire raconter qui se trouve à
proximité du pays de galles mais chut on
a compté très conservateur depuis 200
ans qui n'avait pas été vraiment modifié
et bienvenue jeunes soldats perdus se
compter au profit du parti libéral ce
qui veut dire que la confiance envers le
premier ministre est en train de
s'effriter considérablement elle
s'effrite à la chute de plusieurs
événements successifs qui n'ont pas
facilité les choses il ya bien sûr cette
image absolument ravageuse qui montre
une fête gallifet à la fin de l'année
dernière au 10 downing street et qui
montre que boris johnson ta parfait
respect et lui même une discipline qui
nous est fait respectée par la
population britannique et puis la crise
de confiance sur des affaires comme
cette affaire précisément sur le
continent mais sans charger ou bolton a
voulu protéger les députés du parti
conservateur en essayant de manipuler la
loi pour le protéger contre des tentes
amené des accusations de corruption
notamment sur le leveling cela plus le
fait que vaut rien sans a essayé
également d'imposer le pass and i ter
contre l'avis d'une majorité du parti
conservateur et il a pu le faire
finalement grâce au parti travailliste
toutes ces événements s'est
successivement montre que boris johnson
est en train de connaître un petit peu
la fin de sa de sa confiance et ça c'est
très grave parce que effectivement gérer
une crise pareille
avec une fiche de confiance sérieuse
envers son gouvernement c'est un
problème majeur pour les britanniques
donc le premier ministre finalement qui
est en danger qui pourrait être sur la
sellette à n'importe quel moment
il peut être sur la sellette à n'importe
quel moment dans la mesure où on peut
considérer aujourd'hui que vos rue
johnson n'a plus la confiance de son
parti ça c'est un événement absolument
très important il n'a plus la confiance
de son parti parce que même au sein de
son parti on qui on considère qu'il a
menti il a menti lors de la campagne
pour le brigitte il a menti à d'autres
occasions il a surtout donné la pression
d'être un peu fanfaron est un peu
bouffon et ne pas être sérieux ne peut
reprendre pas sérieusement les choses et
cette crise de confiance effectivement
elle bouscule tout est de savoir dans
une angleterre
très attaché à ses traditions
parlementaires notamment et où une parti
conservateur dit hier très mal cette
manière un petit peu légères de faire de
la politique donc je crois que bon il
dit en faisant elle est aujourd'hui en
danger immédiat on commence même à
parler de sa succession en envisageant
propose son aide actuel secrétaire
d'état aux affaires étrangères
10 rue ce qui pourrait prendre sa place
scenihr que effectivement boris johnson
est dans une situation critique et cela
ça fait que d'un élément tout à fait
nouveau qui montre bien que nos régions
sonne aujourd'hui n'a plus totalement la
confiance de britanniques alors pour
l'instant seuls la france a décidé de
durcir les restrictions vis-à-vis des
voyageurs en provenance du royaume uni
la france qui étaient réunis hier à
bruxelles avec d'autres pays de l'ue eux
pour adopter une position commune pour
justement faire face à la menace du
variant omicron on sait que paris est
déjà engagé dans un bras de fer avec
avec londres sujet notamment des
licences de pêche est-ce que vous pensez
que le royaume uni pourrait à son tour
voilà exiger les mêmes restrictions
vis-à-vis des voyageurs en partance de
la france pour rejoindre le royaume uni
il le fait déjà et je crois que bon
c'est on peut considérer que c'est de
bonne guerre belle maman ou les
restrictions sont d'un côté les lots ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
contrôle de la pandémie est extrêmement
délicat puisque les français savent très
bien que ce qui arrive actuellement au
royaume uni risque d'arriver dans le
curare cours du mois de janvier en
france la pandémie elle se développe à
une allure vertigineuse et ça c'est un
phénomène qui dépasse les frontières qui
rend obligatoire une gestion un peu plus
communes finalement de cette affaire
dans lui c'est que vous savez la grande
bretagne ne fait plus partie de l'union
européenne et donc charge avec la grande
bretagne aujourd'hui pour avoir une
discipline à peu près coordonnées et
compliqué compliqué effectivement vous
l'avez dit par le contentieux en
particulier qui existe entre la france
et la grande bretagne sur la question de
la gestion des immigrés et sur la
question de la pêche en particulier et
bien tout cela excessivement il va
falloir le gérer dans des conditions
difficiles mais tout le monde le sait le
gouvernement de boris johnson et n'est
plus aujourd'hui en position de pouvoir
exiger vis-à-vis notamment d'un de ses
partenaires européens et c'est ça la
nouveauté c'est à dire que le rampeau
aujourd'hui a maintenu une certaine
forme d'unité et face à cela le royaume
uni est dans une position fragile et
c'est ça qui va rendre extrêmement
compliqué la suite de la coopération
entre les deux ensembles merci beaucoup
en tout cas françois poulet mathis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste des institutions européennes